there's a bunch of new content coming to
Animal Crossing over the next few weeks
so let's break down all you need to know
first the island is getting some new
visitors leaf the sloth will start
appearing in your plaza and he sells
seeds for flowers and shrubs which are
being added to new horizons meanwhile
jolly red will dock his boat at your
private beach and you can talk to him to
purchase furniture and works of art you
can donate legit artwork you purchased
to the Museum's new art wing to leaf red
and the art wing are being added via a
free update on April 23rd which is also
when nature day kicks off as you might
expect the event involves a lot of
flowers trees and the new shrubs there
will be special Nuuk miles + objectives
for tending to these while the event
runs until May 4th those dates actually
overlap with another event May Day that
will run from May 1st through the 7th
during which time you'll be able to
visit special islands that are separate
from the Nook miles mystery tours one of
these has a hedge maze and you can spot
fan-favorite Rover among the bushes May
has yet another Animal Crossing event on
the horizon International Museum day
will run from the 18th through the end
of the month during which time you'll
fill out a stamp card with the fish
insects and fossils you've collected
there's some sort of special reward for
collecting these stamps then the wedding
season event will run for the whole
month of June visit harps Island and
you'll encounter the alpaca couple Reese
and Cyrus you will be able to take
special anniversary photos and earn
wedding-themed rewards for doing so New
Horizons is getting really busy with all
this stuff so be sure to stay tuned to
games Pot for all the info on future
Animal Crossing updates